Tiffany I couldn't be happier for you
that you found your lifelong partner in
Brian he is kind to you he treats you
with respect he doesn't sleep with your
therapist and then blame you for the
infidelity you have to try online dating
not time that Brian
[Music]
you're pretty I'm sorry yes so friend
you use it too no I just needed
something cheap oh I met a guy his name
is Daniel oh my gosh what's he like he's
nice we have things in common oh do you
like James Cameron oh yeah he made Jerry
Maguire right that's kevin krill oh the
guy that looks like the evil scary mime
no that's that's a movie The Crow I
think I saw a trailer for that one
sometimes we run out of stuff to say to
each other but I think that that just
means that we're happy to exist in
silence mostly though I'm just excited
to be in a relationship on Valentine's
Day this year did you almost almost
[Music]
you're living with her yeah I mean it is
cheaper to split rent so like why not
when you love someone you know instantly
you can't wait to see that
never want to leave them something just
clicks and you can never imagine
yourself with another person read long
and you think God knowing that you never
settle for anything less
yeah yeah totally feel the same way
[Music]
so do you want to get married